let's go to andrew in iowa city my
fiance and i are
engaged and uh we're scheduled to get
married here in july
okay and i'm having trouble convincing
her to change her last name to mine
sweet okay i feel like i feel like i've
got her boxed it
but i was wondering if you could help me
out with that yeah
so first of all never boxing your person
you're going to marry
right yeah that's a losing proposition
everybody loses when you try to box in
another person especially
one that you love okay so walk me
through this
um y'all you ask her to marry you and
she's like yes i
i will and y'all get excited and then
she's like bt dubs i'm gonna keep my
last name
yeah so she um so she comes she's a
single child like a
single child in the family like only
sibling right
okay so she wants to hyphenate my
last name with hers oh she wants to keep
she wants yours but she just wants yours
to be part of
a bigger name yes okay but and my
argument is well it's still not the same
okay
because i wouldn't have to agree you
know
um hyphenate my name either
and i was just like you know i can't the
kids names wouldn't be the same either
if it's if they're gonna have my last
name
okay catch where i'm going yeah i do
so why does this why is why does it
matter to you
i because historically in my family
everybody even in my neck of the woods
like
i've only noticed until recently that
some people changed the last name and
some people
don't with the age of social media okay
um
but historically my family the bride
takes the groom's last name and that's
kind of
how it is i mean i haven't really
understood why
or i wasn't explained why that happens
or why that is
or like why or i've never even
heard of the struggle of coming to that
realization if that makes sense
yeah so um there's a couple of things so
my wife was
uh was a scholar she was a an
academician
and she had her maiden name
and she had done some writing under her
maiden name
and then when she got married there
would be some sort of
um disconnect between the person who
wrote under this name than the scholar
who's writing under this name right
and so i'm the one who actually
encouraged her i said man just keep your
middle name
and we happen to all work at the same
university
she was a professor and i said man this
is going to get real confusing with
multiple dr deloney's walking around why
don't you just go buy your
i was the one trying to get her to go by
her maiden name just just for the
separation
of church and state right i wanted my
students to be able to say man
dr so-and-so is the worst and
not feel like i can't talk bad about
your wife because that's one of their
teachers right so
she didn't do it she said no i'm like so
we actually had the opposite
conversation y'all are having
i've also heard it in broader circles
about
just as you mentioned there's no reason
to do it other than tradition
and i love my last name and i don't like
your last name
i don't know i want to be married to you
but i don't want to associate myself
with
your family and i want i'm the only kid
i want to keep this last name going
because we didn't have any sons
to follow that same tradition so there's
a bunch of different patriarchal reasons
why we just take the last name and the
woman loses her name
and her autonomy all these other all
these reasons
at the end of the day none of that stuff
matters
any more than why do you want her to
take your last name
and why does she not want to
yeah and for me i just want it to be the
same because i feel like it's in the
same pool
we're in the same you know everything's
the same and it doesn't add any
confusion to anything
and she wants to keep it because she was
an athlete in high school and in college
and i was just like you know if you get
into those hall of fames
you could go in as that last name
because i didn't know you before that
happened
and i think that's kind of fair because
i wouldn't expect her to do that
so uh for me i just wanted to be
everything the same and here's the thing
the everything's the same for you is
easier because for you nothing changes
and for her everything's different for
it to be everything the same for you
does that make sense yeah but i i do get
man this is just the tradition i didn't
even think to that we needed to think
about this
right so walk me through what happens if
she chooses to hyphenate her name
i got a sense from you there's a
tradition there you don't even know
anybody in your community that does that
is that going to make you feel like less
of a man and it's no shame if it does
i'm just
i'm i'm trying to drill in a little bit
here does that make you feel less than
not really i just feel like it's
kind of a control thing and not that i
don't want to have control over her per
se but like
i don't want to be not
unified in decisions if that makes sense
yes that's where i'm going
is this is a bigger conversation because
for
somebody it may feel like a power move
for somebody else it may feel like
they're not going all in right and for
somebody else
they've had regional or
national acclaim under their name
and getting married means they're giving
that up
right and it's gonna they're they're
being absorbed into one person which
they are
right it just makes this whole thing
messy which i want to get beneath that
which is where you are which is
is this making you rethink how y'all are
going to have conversations about hard
things
for instance i want to spank my kid
we're not spanking our kid i don't care
what you say
or i want to live in this neighborhood
i'm never living in that neighborhood
i want a two-story house i want a one
story right
these conversations will be will go on
for the duration of your relationship
forever
something tells me that if you're having
this conversation
there's something else beneath it that
makes you
go what is that
i i don't know i just
[Music]
i just want to make sure that like we're
all all in
on the same page and i just don't
i can't put a finger on it i can't
really
narrow down what that is what's another
argument you've lost before
um i don't know i'm a pretty easygoing
guy so i don't like
you know i don't so does this hurt the
fact that you said hey i really this
means a lot to me and she said i don't
care
not that she didn't care but that she's
so
reluctant at best okay steven hyphenate
let me ask you this at the end of the
day if she says hey
i'm keeping my maiden name we're getting
married is that a deal breaker for you
not really it's just like it seems so
not abnormal for my
historical for my family tree i guess
yeah
and what about for her if you say hey i
it means the world to me that
you do this this the traditional way
that we've done this
and you take my name
is that a deal breaker for her i don't i
don't think so
but it just gets it's this conversation
just seems like
it doesn't ever go anywhere yeah you're
exactly right
and i think the problem the reason it's
not going anywhere
is because nobody's being honest about
the root here
and the root here is you both have put
on the table this means a lot to me and
the other person hasn't moved and so
this is not about last names anymore
although it is
it's more important about whoa
how do we make decisions in this family
what's the 5149 what is compromise going
to look like what does
um like i said earlier when we get into
bigger batter issues as we move on to
our how are we gonna do this
how are we gonna make these calls and
here's what you've got to do before you
get married
is you're going to have to sit down with
a with a premarital counselor
and i want you to navigate some of these
communication issues some of these
values issues
some of these belief issues and more
importantly i want you to come up with a
game plan for how you're going to work
through some of these things
i don't personally have an issue either
which way
on the last name thing i've got friends
who are musicians who are married who
have different last names
but i think legally they may be the sa i
don't know how any of that stuff works
with them i just know i call them
different last names out in public
and i know that i tried to talk my wife
into it for a publishing reason
but it didn't occur to me that the
downstream challenges it would cause
the other side of that is i also know it
can really
feel like somebody's not all in and i
can also feel like
hey if we're just doing this for
tradition so you don't feel weird
this means a lot to me and so every
couple is gonna have to make this
decision for themselves
every couple's gonna have to get in a
room and come up with the architecture
for how we have hard conversations
how we disagree and then how we come to
terms with
the um the outcome
but i want every guy especially to hear
this
just quote unquote i just want things to
be normal
tends to mean you get your way i just
want things to be the way they've always
been
tends to mean somebody loses their name
they get their voice squashed and you
feel good about where you're at
and so if you feel yourself saying why
can't things just be the way they were
that's a good conversation to say whoa i
need to learn some new skills i want to
dig in this a little bit deeper because
there's something bigger going on
i really appreciate your vulnerability
here andrew it's hard to make this call
and to say hey i'm struggling with this
and i don't really i know why i just
wanted to be normal
and easy let's just move on i appreciate
your heart man that's hard to say out
loud
and i also don't want to dismiss the
fact that y'all having a hard
conversation because this is bigger than
just
the last name and to everybody out there
going oh my gosh can they just get over
no it's a big deal
and you don't get to choose what's a big
deal in somebody else's heart and you
they didn't invite you into their
relationship to comment on it right
but you guys got to figure out the hard
conversation architecture
asap before you get married because the
conversations that you're going to have
in your in your marriage
are only going to get harder and harder
and harder